we can wait but i don't know bring the
king
probably swinging it so b3 go a4
looks winning
your point is oh just wait
you wait and if a5 and f4 you can still
look at that
wow but then it must be winning he must
have calculated it all
it takes takes oh he was hesitating off
oh that's a that's a game he knows the
structures
so that's
it's also just supernova a4 a4
and take on b5 hey
k3 i already have king c4
i i should say i can lose a move a4 king
a6 like okay
king ah king b6 oh i take
king b3
and we win g6 f3 and if the king goes
back king a4 b5 killed before
no no he's got it figured out yeah and
voice check resigns
while the world champion advances to the
next round
and yeah found a clean solution in a
position where things were easy for him
magnus was saying yeah i told you you
shouldn't have talked all this trash
after drawing with the white pieces it
made me
it became personal for me
puts on his mask magnus carson moving on
to the next round very tough fight by
radek voiter
two classical games where anything could
have happened
and yeah playing magnus toe-to-toe here